[Music]
we're really excited to have one of the
best saxophonist in the world he's
coming to MIT cuz he knows of the talent
of these students I mean festival jazz
ensemble is just one of the best musical
groups in Boston
they're still close to a million Puerto
Ricans without electricity my
grandmother just receives electricity
like a week ago it's been five months
[Music]
with this concert the Jats ensemble's
initiative was to be able to collect all
this money and donate it to the Puerto
Rico Recovery Fund which is a long-term
vision for the island
[Music]
there's still a lot of chaos
unfortunately the one on in the island
so we're just trying to really create
awareness anything you can do to help is
greatly needed and greatly appreciate it
by the folks down there I have a lot of
friends from artists - you know most
small business owners who decided to
stay there and do what they could to
build that country back up so I wrote
this piece for them thinking about the
resiliency and the courage a lot of
these people in Puerto Rico a lot of the
people who are trying to help out the
situation there
[Music]
how to create more resilient
infrastructures electrical grids housing
water systems try to find ways of
decentralizing the whole thing so that
if like one tower fall some people would
be able to like sustain their own micro
grid solar panels and stuff like that so
I think that's where I like T really
comes in right is to try to bring all
the innovation that are in these labs to
come to Puerto Rico make a difference in
people's lives we're looking for the
future to have a bit of like a set up
externship where you could have students
work on actual projects that could
benefit the Puerto Rican community and
society on the island brainstorming
ideas and a bit of like consulting and
designing I hope that young people don't
take this as a kind of a defeat but more
so as an opportunity to grow and be part
of the Puerto Rico tomorrow if the young
people give up the rest is just gonna
collapse we can't let our country die
[Music]
[Applause]
wimpy I don't know
[Music]